how's it going there citizens of the
reject nation that is I channeled back
once again for for a how have you not
seen this movie reaction we are going
back for another Disney classic and
animated Disney classic from the the
early 2000s and that is Lilo and Stitch
I am very excited to finally be catching
up with this but when you're done
leaving that comment about how have you
not seen this movie already John I don't
believe you go ahead and hit that like
button uh helps us out very much over
here let's YouTube know what's good and
what you like to see as well hit that
notification Bell and subscription
button to get notified whenever one of
these reactions or something else that
might pique your interest pops up here
on the channel as always as well if you
want to get the full experience with me
sync up with your own copy of Lilo and
Stitch and watch alongside me for the
full hour and 28 minutes come on over to
our patreon page patreon.com the real
rejects we also have tons of other shows
and movies over there with reaction High
lights as well as watch alongs included
it's a lot of fun come check it out and
if you want to support the channel and
get some fresh drip in the process go on
over to our Shop zeroedition.com store
got a lot of cool designs over there
including a brand new who influences the
influencers T-shirt Greg came up with
it's a sweet design I'm jealous and hey
without further Ado let's go to the
beach it's time for Lilo and Stitch I'm
excited it's you know it's still winter
but yeah it's summer in our hearts right
let's do this
love when they do something
neat with the Disney logo lead
scientists of Galaxy defense Industries
you stand before this Council
experimentation
that's a pretty Grim charge for her we
believe you
you're making clones on kamino what you
see before you is the first of a new
species
I call it adorable merchandise
or experiment 626. he is bulletproof
fireproof and can think fast
he's only instinct to destroy everything
he touches
you had me up until the end there
I like that he barfs out little
nuts and bolts and things idiot
scientist under arrest
[Music]
of course you do
cool like I wasn't quite expecting this
part I know we're probably not going to
spend much time here but like this is a
cool world the council has banished you
to Exile on a desert asteroid these guns
are locked onto your genetic signature
they won't shoot anyone but you
damn Captain veggie is on duty
yeah secure the South
[Laughter]
ever seen someone shoved all the way
inside a gun before does this uh look
infected to you
wow a nomadic colony of sorts
traversing the Galaxy
I feel like you should have calibrated
your smart guns to count account for
something like this
like this sort of
gooey texture of their lasers too
what was that I don't think he's on the
ship anymore confirmed he's taken a
police cruiser nice
dude GTA Stitch going hard out here
[Music]
yeah
that's it we've got it we've got it
uh-oh do not engage
now you're in for a Hawaiian vacation of
a lifetime you're still in hyperspace
where will he exit section zero zero
five area 51. area 51. what is that
water most of the planet is covered in
it he won't survive and move to his
molecular density is too great he'll
drown
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
of course
Earth is a protected Wildlife Reserve
yeah we've been using it to rebuild the
mosquito population which need remind
you is an endangered species
can we not simply destroy the island no
crazy head the the mosquitoes food of
choice primitive humanoid life oh if you
master
but they're very delicate in fact every
time an asteroid strikes their Planet
they have to begin life all over oh my
God this is taking me back whoo then Mr
pleately would you send for his
extraction does he have a brother close
grandmother perhaps
the the scientist six to six will not
come easily
maybe a direct hit from plasma cannon
might stun him long enough to plasma
cannon granted do we have a bargain dang
hmm but it's a delicate Planet who's
gonna control him
you will yes of course you will
on what Poor Pitiful
defenseless planet has my monstrosity
been Unleashed
good transition
don't worry Earth is prepared for this
sandwich fish
oh little one
let's go Alan Silvestri made some
classic scores over the years
I love a good opening title sequence
some aloe vera on you my guy
based on an idea
by Chris Sanders I like that the way
they phrase that just makes it sound
like he was like ah
ah like an alien in Hawaii
and then they'd created everything else
based off of that
hey
wow
why are you all wet every Thursday I
take Pudge the fish a peanut butter
sandwich fudge is a fish
he sounds so tired of this
[Music]
[__]
friends don't let friends become
cannibals
[Applause]
oh
we should call your sister no I'll be
good I just want to dance
I practice
oh little ones don't worry you'll be a
world-class dancer in no time
are you gonna let her head is too big so
I pretend the bug Light eggs in her ears
and she's upset because she only has a
few more days too
oh I'll hang out with you childhood me
would be about that this is already
pulling in my heart's drinks
uh oh
that guy's gonna come back God the
animation's Beautiful
[Music]
Heartbreak Hotel
oh I'm gonna stop you in the blender
push puree then bake you into a pie and
feed it to the social worker and when he
says this is great what's your secret
I'm gonna say
love
get safe
[Music]
oh damn
body and in question yes I'm Nani nice
to meet you mister
bubbles that's a string yes I know are
you going to invite me in Nani do you
have the meats Nani what cup what kind
of social worker is this guy
looks like he works for a Crime Boss or
like he is the crime Buzz
hey
so lemonade
do you often leave your sister home
alone no never
oh God
ah we had to run to the store to get
some
cleaning supplies
special classification
did you ever kill anyone we're getting
off the subject
four groups and up both ways before
crossing the street and take long naps
and get disciplined she disciplines me
real good sometimes five times a day
hahaha
oh
[Music]
practical voodoo
there's there's an edge on the writing
of this that I very much enjoy my
friends need to be punished
call an exorcist after all this in case
you're wondering this did not go well
[Laughter]
boy oh no no no no no he's gonna be back
in there like instantaneously
the pizza box oven door
that's great do you want to be taken
away
answer me no no you don't understand
[Music]
you're such a pain why do you sell me by
a rabbit instead
I don't like because it's sticky like
you oh
[Music]
everyone rings around you logically
you and me both sisters we're a broken
family aren't we maybe a little oh
[Music]
shouldn't have yelled at you we're
sisters it's our job
yeah well from now on I like you better
as a sister than a mom oh
and you like me better as a sister than
a rabbit right yes yes
I do
that is a Nuance man
yes you capture the real life
real people
nice timing
[Music]
I need someone to be my friend
someone who won't run away
the nicest Angel you
great timing great great transition they
just got the dearest little girl to play
Lilo
damn it Disney
crying already we're not 10 minutes into
this
You Can't Kill Them All
a truck from Mad Max over here
witness me
30. you
know do we have a lobster door no we
have a dog door we are getting a dog we
are taking home the cast of Oliver and
Company
hello
are there any aminals in here
oh no
this is your turtle in the back
[Music]
yeah you're clever
where do those go oh
wow all of our dogs are adoptable
except that one
[Laughter]
does it have to be this dog
yes he's good I can tell
his name is Stitch
oh no that's not a real name
it's a dog name
oh that was sweet
that good why don't you run
I'm coming
stay out of the roads okay
is that the giant spider Invasion or
something or tarantula I love when they
do that
they put some kind of old movie or stock
footage on screen
yeah
ouch mean
he's loose his destructive programming
is taking effect he will be irresistibly
drawn to large cities where he will back
up sewers reverse street signs and steal
everyone's left shoe no not the left
shoe he's already committed Grand Theft
big wheel
God
I love the blending of Animation in this
I feel like this was it at like a Nexus
point in the early 2000s where you got
like very classical live on an island
with no large cities
nice
with no large cities Great for an alien
invasion
but yeah it's the blending of like
classical art styles and the Really
crisp character animations the
occasional computer animation
beautiful
oh
ouch
whoa no what you gotta learn some dog if
you're gonna blend in my guy
cool
oh here we go
nice
[Applause]
oh no
you sure it's a dog he used to be a
collie before he got ran over
yum cheese
oh
egg
[Laughter]
hahaha you're not doing anything David I
told you I can't I
oh
she likes her butt and fancy hair I know
I have a diary
you do have good hair my guy and I'm
sure your butt is is just as firm and
and
pert
[Music]
um
whole head in the mouth
is that your dog ah all is well please
go about your business I'm okay your
head looks swollen actually she's just
ugly
yeah
this is not working out no
the manager's a vampire and he wanted me
to join his Legion of the undead
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's obviously mutated from something
else we have to take him back whoa what
about
a battle you haven't been here that long
means family oh
there's a theme
nobody gets left behind or forgotten ah
I love their relationship down
you don't touch this don't ever touch it
oh no is that Mom and Dad
oh covering from surgery
[Music]
period of course
make something for a change
it's a little sit here San Francisco
it's it's San Francisco
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
goodness gracious me they're feasting on
you my dude I never gave him a greater
purpose
what must it be like to have nothing
not even memories to visit
I guess you got to create your own
The Ugly Duckling see he's sad because
he
[Music]
always breaks my heart his family hears
him crying and they find him then the
ugly duckling is happy because he knows
where he belongs oh you're the ugly
duckling you're both the ugly duckling
look
[Music]
[Laughter]
are there like Hollow Chambers in there
despite his amazing density you lost
I just quit that
then a child
so sorry about that what is that thing
that's my puppy
thus far you have been adrift in the
sheltered Harbor of my patients
new job
model citizen
good day
my man's got bars
[Music]
he
hold it like this put your fingers here
see now you try
shred Stitch but I just hide Teddy in
the tour season in
[Music]
that is that is that is virtuosic play
oh we might have something good now kiss
him
ugh I'm sure Elvis had his bad days too
oh goodness actually I do think we have
an opening really okay
oh that would be so great you have no
idea how badly I need this oh no oh no
[Music]
no no no
bad bad bad
[Music]
times the fun saver
[Applause]
it's all going so difficult for a guy in
his ice cream
oh
come back not Pamela Anderson we can
talk about this hey I might not be a
doctor but I know that there's no better
cure for a sour face than a couple of
boards and some Choice waves
what do you think that is a bar
oh
you're about to find a new passion
foreign
you can do it
oh
yeah
not bad
killing it Nani whoa
good catch never surfed but this is
making me want to I used to skateboard
which are totally the same
[Music]
I want to be built into a sand castle
oh
I love the way they're capturing the
water too
the below surface shots through the
waves like ah
thank you
oh you guys
oh
[Music]
oh Jeeps this morning bigger
oh
[Music]
kicked him in the head no
whoa
damn
oh
he's unconscious but I think he's alive
do some emergency CPR oh okay he's fine
this isn't what it looks
like I know you're trying Nadi but you
need to think about what's best for Lilo
you just don't have that removes you
from the picture
no
I really believe they had a chance
then you came along
oh
fix this you better fix this
yeah
that's us before
it was rainy and they went for a drive
oh no Disney no
what happened to yours I hear you cry at
night
do you dream about them
you dream about the torturous
laboratory process your family's little
now but if you want you could be part of
it you could be our baby then we'd raise
you to be good
oh
family means nobody gets left behind or
forgotten
how could you not I
for everyone that leaves
oh
lost oh
[Music]
ugh
my heart
I mean you come out here this could be
your chance to redeem yourself Captain
gun too how soon will you be prepared to
leave
immediately I thought you'd never ask
Donald Trump
yes that's it come quietly
or waiting waiting
oh
don't have one maybe I could you're
built to destroy
you can never belong nurture come on
nurture I think I found you a job you
what old man kuakini storm but we gotta
hurry I'm gonna be right back lock the
door and don't answer it for anyone okay
not even the social worker guy
oh David I owe you one that's okay
we'll call it even
come on you too
oh my yes yep yep right on time
hound dog
rocking all the time you know you didn't
originally write that song though
put you back together again
you taller and not so fluffy
I like fluffy I do too
you could do is a makeover I tried to
give you my good looks but let's face it
something went wrong no
no oh
teamwork
[Music]
that is a toiletries kit what have you
done to the girl
the Bulls
don't call Bubbles about this
punch buggy
that's where that came from everything's
under control Lilo who was that oh good
my dog down the chainsaw
don't hang
yes the the Stitch Chainsaw Massacre
oh boy oh boy oh boy
you won't be disappointed I'll show up
early to help with the morning
yeah don't turn left
yep
no
no oh boy oh boy oh boy
please don't do this
you know I have no choice no
no
that it needs to be
no seems clear to me that you need her a
lot more than she needs you
ouch oh no
you're one of them
oh
surprise of course
surprise [__]
there you go all buckled up for the trip
that almost sounded like not on ball
Mountain for a second whoa
oh my God
what
Lilo also the existence of
extraterrestrial life but but also
damn it
you're under arrest Freedom Is Right
Freedom Is Right bring her back oh we
can't do that uh-huh that would be
misuse of Galactic resources dude Ohana
means family yep
nobody gets left behind
after all you put me through you expect
me to help you just like that
fine
what exactly are we doing rescue we're
gonna get Leela hey
do it team
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice little Jaws tribute
[Music]
me I thought you'd like to know that the
little Abomination is
mooning us
she must already know they called
why are we
I was gonna say
you are not as aerodynamic you're doing
a pretty decent job of evading but still
oh
wow
[Music]
wow get off my ship
oh damn
don't leave me okay okay
oh so Earnest Frogger
oh oh
no
what is your plan
[Music]
sweet abomination
nice use of chemistry
[Music]
nobody's just left behind
ah YouTube
you crazy kids
bubbles is definitely gonna understand
after this I am retiring you captain
ouch
none of this
stitch them if it wasn't for Stitch
huh
yes let's just say goodbye
yes yes
I love her reactions in that moment
who are you
this is my family
family
for good
still good
absolutely model citizen bubbles
you take them you're stealing and I will
sue you from across the Galaxy all about
rules
you look familiar periods are all about
CIA Roswell
1973. yes
a sentence that shall be henceforth
served out here
on Earth yes ma'am on on a earth don't
let those two get on my ship
are they exiled too yeah I guess they
are what a cool looking ship too CIA
former
Save the Planet once convinced an alien
race that mosquitoes were an endangered
species
foreign
[Music]
damn you just got Distortion built in
to your biology yes oh nice digs
[Music]
you surf day
that looks like quite a cake oh and even
bubbles came oh
cool I love little Jetsons noises
yes
I have vengeance
how lovely
oh it went visited Elvis's Estates okay
he went to Graceland
yeah oh
how lovely man
that was so nice
and I love too that you've got you've
got all this music and it's not a
musical but there is still you know
music present throughout and and you
know as a sort of part of the movie's
identity so great
love these family photos too this is
great
nice nice use of that Motif for the
ending credits here
just a hawk
it's Crush
it's a little crush
ah how lovely
yes oh I love it I love that they yeah
they cut him out they made a cutout to
put someone in the picture that's that's
awesome
oh
oh my friends oh that was such a delight
oh man
that was so delightful I really wish I
had gotten to see that in the theaters
when I was a kid and I hope that
somebody screens it you know at some
point coming up because I would love to
see some of this artwork like it's funny
this movie was doing so many things but
this really pulled me in and I could see
why it you know it has kind of stood the
test of time as one of their Classics I
mean I feel like they spun a lot of
other stuff out of this obviously not
that franchising something makes it good
but um this is yeah A really lovely
convergence of so many different things
and I was very dazzled by it because I
feel like you know again these movies
are in some ways very Compact and very
straightforward and some it's funny
going back to some of these Disney
movies that I missed I feel like some of
them uh have fallen into a category
where I'm like okay that was really fun
maybe a little slight but fun like you
know kind of throws you right into
things whereas this was one of the
examples of one that feels like very
full and well-rounded and rich with a
bunch of different things and it's just
done so with such efficiency but also
such compassion that yeah it just feels
like kind of the perfect package like I
really love this like I I'd be curious
to see in a few days time how I'm
feeling but yeah like this is one that
even seeing it now I feel like there's
so much to appreciate and I loved yeah
just the juxtaposition like the blending
of these two flavors you know you start
out with this like you know wild sort of
fun like not pulse pounding exactly but
you know you're starting out with like a
Sci-Fi fugitive situation where you have
this like bioengineered destruction
machine in 626
and the ensuing Manhunt as he escapes uh
their uh you know capture uh but then
you know pretty soon I I think they
proportioned things out really nicely
because that could have been in danger
of feeling like it was from a different
movie or something like that but I think
that or or it could have felt random I
guess you know being that he crashed
lands in Hawaii this movie has a certain
amount of that culture imbued into it
and especially like you know the the
convergence of Hawaiian culture with
American culture I think specifically
and sort of it paints it it puts it it's
sort of an interesting point in time and
and place and yeah like I feel like
having the uh uh sci-fi element could
just feel like any old random thing but
it felt really natural here and it felt
like a really fun way of you know
creating a universe that you could
expand on not that again franchising is
like the the sign of quality but like
yeah it made this engrossing little
world and then managed to engross me
again with just like actual real life
problems and endearing characters and
yeah I mean I really loved Lilo and I
loved Nani and I loved their
relationship with each other and I
thought they did a nice job of making
something that was like thrilling and
fun and even though it's not a musical
it still has music throughout and music
is an important part of it and uh and
yeah like you know it manages I think to
draw a pretty nuanced picture of a
struggling family like like when they
have that moment where she addresses
that whole idea that I like you better
when as my sister than as my mom and and
you know I like you better as my sister
than as my daughter or whatever that was
like that's it's such a I mean it's like
it's a it's a hard Bittersweet thing and
the movie doesn't ever shy away from
stuff like that and even if Cobra
Bubbles is like a pretty funny unlikely
character even that is is sort of
perfect like you can see how he might
have some level of compassion you can
also see why he wouldn't be completely
why you would have any patience at all
for them adopting this alien
um it's it's like it's it's goofy even
in a way but in a way that I really
really appreciated and had a lot of fun
with and I think everybody really honed
in perfectly on and I mean like again
the the the voice acting alone I thought
was really great uh Lilo like she's so
endearing and and such a a great little
rascal because I think it would be easy
for that character to become annoying
and I never was I I was only ever as
annoyed with her as you know like Nani
was supposed to be or something like
that and vice versa like I think they
did really nicely to flesh these
characters out and to make them both
expressive within the animation but also
just within the drama at hand and and
drawing these situations that again lend
themselves to hijinks when stitches
around and when those things are
happening but also lend themselves to
real life precarious situations you know
again that whole thing where she goes
home on her own after dance class locks
her sister are out and then the social
worker shows up in the midst of just
like a bad moment like that could have
easily become Halloween ends
um but yeah just like the the again
deafness at which they wove between the
two and having also the uh what are
their names I have the IMDb pulled up
here uh Jumba and and pleakly which
Kevin McDonald getting some Kids in the
Hall love in there and I know I've heard
uh uh David Ogden steyer's voice before
um but yeah like having them as you know
these sort of the the essentially like
the buddy cop Duos chasing them and
trying to apprehend them and the you
know further you know supporting
characters of the Galactic Federation
and all that stuff like I really enjoyed
the you know sort of flavors of other
movies that that lent whether it kept
reminding me of like a gross point blank
even though it's not like a one-to-one
comparison but how you have like
um Hank Azaria and uh oh I forget the
other actor's name he's got the mustache
uh you know like they're kind constantly
bumping into these Hitmen and they're
constantly like kind of at odds and
they're all aware of each other you know
it was fun because you get to watch I
thought they did a really nice job of
having it be yeah like Stitch is mostly
out for himself for a while he's just
trying to evade these two and Destroy as
much as he can but then they introduce a
kind of interesting like that I I like
the fact that you have this this mad
genius scientist guy also being like
he's like kind of sympathetic in a way
like he he has like created I don't know
what what it kind of the ethics of what
you know created Stitch are exactly but
you know it doesn't seemed like a
deplorable character in his uh depths uh
not that's exactly the right way to put
that but you know uh and having you know
completely be so uh sort of Plucky and
you know buy the book you know like
they're a good Odd Couple but also
they're like a good couple to observe
Stitch and I love the whole thing about
the mosquitoes and like you know uh
Cobra convincing them you know saving
Earth by basically convincing them that
this is some kind of nature preserved
for mosquitoes
um especially you know out here when uh
summertime hits you know like the
mosquito struggle is real so I guess if
that was the cost thank you
um but yeah having it be that they go to
this Nature Preserve so for their
purposes there's some reason to preserve
it and for our purposes of course you
know we would like it not to be
completely destroyed or terraformed or
obliterated or whatever
um but yeah like that draws like the
right amount of stakes and then it's fun
to watch is yeah you know Lilo you know
goes through the process again of
opening up to somebody and having a bond
with a friend and and maybe trusting
that they won't just leave
and even that like like that was I think
again there's that Meme of like you know
if you're a parent in a Disney movie you
know like dude you're you're probably
dead already like you know if you've
made it to part way through the movie
even well done
um but yeah like this does address again
some difficult walks of life to deal
with and certain you know ways in which
people have to grow up earlier than they
should maybe that anyone should have to
and I thought they tempered that nicely
with her growth and and just you know
learning to uh understand better what
the scope of her family is and how to
take care of them and everybody's sort
of checking back in on the Ohana theme
that family means nobody gets left
behind and nobody gets forgotten yeah I
love that she invokes that at first as
sort of like a card to pull to get what
she wants but you know that really does
get tested and tempered over the course
of the movie and yeah going back to that
point from before I love that you have
the two guys in a position to observe
Stitch
because then that brings up this other
conversation uh about you know like he
doesn't really have any sort of like
greater purpose that I imbued him with
and so they kind of let this sort of
again there are so many like little
subplots happening Below in between the
A and B plot of the movie plots of the
movie
um but I love that too that like it
allows for Stitch's growth as a being as
a creature you know as this sort of
halfway like he's feral at first you
know he seems very creature-like and
then as the movie goes he learns to
speak uh English and everybody kind of
speaks English except it seems like
Stitch also is speaking some other alien
language that's maybe his own or
whatever but yeah like over the course
of the movie he learns to better
communicate and clearly has much better
of a grip on it than he lets on it first
or or after a while but yeah just
introducing this idea of what level of
nature is at work here and what level of
nurture could maybe you know give him
he's a new creature like as much as he
is like a threat and and you know Adept
at destruction at the same time he's
just like a new life form so like maybe
he deserves a shot and maybe he can grow
to maybe not just want to destroy
everything and I think the way that they
realize that in the story and the way
that they uh spilled those odds over
back and forth between Lilo and Stitch
like you know Lilo has to not you know
uh wreak havoc on the world around her
inadvertently through just losing
herself in Joy or uh or despair or
whatever and it's uh more Primal way
stitch has to do the same thing and so
yeah like the I thought they Blended
nicely the real Stakes of you know like
the sister needing to have a job needing
to support them maybe the social worker
is going to separate them and you know
everybody seems to be on or they seem to
be on really thin ice with just
everybody around like yeah you know it
was it was a nice set of plates that
they managed to spin because it feels
like you know sort of a full fantasy
sci-fi Adventure you know again it's
it's and and that is like drawing I
think in a very nice way like you know
these 2000 zero Disney movies and
watching The Emperor's New Groove
certainly uh had this effect where it's
like you can tell this is Disney for a
slightly different era it's a little
more Rye it's a little more Punchy and
quippy and the jokes and the humor
um but this I thought I mean you know
for good reason
uh Emperor's New Groove is like a very
quippy movie it's you know a very much a
comedy and this I thought you know had
just the right amount of that and just
the right amount of that for me as if
you were borrowing from uh just you know
sci-fi in general and sci-fi Adventure
fantasy movies and things like that and
so you know part of it feels like it
sort of skews even though like this
would be fun I think for you know the
family what you think of when you think
of a family movie but also you know it
skews kind of a little bit older too for
you know fans particularly of that Vibe
and aesthetic and yeah like in a way
this almost reminded me a little bit of
Avatar because it's like you have this
alien race it's like kind of like a
reverse Avatar somehow it's like you
have this alien race and you know they
send one of their people else they send
some people to Earth to elsewhere and
then you know you sort of learn that uh
terrain and you see what that ecosystem
is like and what the experience is of
living in that world and it's like here
it's you have the surf scenes and things
like that you're spending time in town
and you're you're sitting around you
know at the table while you know Nani's
doing her weight service and all that
stuff and and then we're you know back
underwater and the way they captured
water like the animation in this movie I
thought was really cool too across the
board and there were moments where I was
like okay there's a bit of us what
appears to be a bit of a CG effect
um you know for certain of the more
sci-fi elements and then you have the
very crisp you know uh uh sort of hero
character animations but like I I loved
how much of this felt like really
tangible artwork on screen uh so much of
it you know was watercolors and things
like that which you know I I I used to
paint hard to admit but I used to paint
uh you know I I I used to love painting
in watercolor and I love seeing just the
way they Blended all that you know like
those more tangible feeling painting
like uh you know backdrops and
establishing shots and settings and
things like that I don't know it's just
like a really a lively combination of
visual Styles and yeah especially when
they're in the water and the way that
they you know depict the camera so to
speak you know kind of being at surface
level or at least you know the eye
whatever we're seeing through our vision
is sort of at surface level so it you
know like there's a lot that goes into
the perspective of that and you know
making that feel uh like transportive
you know to the ocean and it's funny
like seeing something like Avatar
recently that is so you know again photo
real or is that you can have something
like this that if you watch it on a big
enough TV at moments you're like wow you
know like where you really are sort of
flying through space or we're you know
taking a deep dive underwater or falling
off the surfboard or whatever and this
made me uh nostalgic for my uh you know
I never surfed but you know because I
was interested in skateboarding I was
also tangentially interested in Surf
life so uh yeah you know it's nice it's
fun uh and two I mean like I loved even
the little other motifs they had uh
they're you know you get like the Elvis
music which you know even that was kind
of a neat nod to just other Realms of
Cinema because yeah I mean Elvis made a
ton of like beach movies and and you
know I I I'm not like necessarily know
if all of them are in Hawaii but I I'm
sure at least one or a few of them are
and uh you know I just thought that was
kind of like a neat aspect uh uh you
know say what you will about Elvis you
know I thought that was kind of just
like a neat aspect of just yeah like the
life and the culture and especially just
like what these characters is doing you
know with their time and their passion
and I love that she's got like her wall
of photos and the little dolls that she
creates and and yeah just like you know
it shows you who the characters are
through little things like that it makes
him feel more alive uh little flourishes
I like I love the little movie on the TV
and the window and stuff like that like
this feels like a A really lovely piece
of artwork and uh yeah it just manages
to do all the things that it's doing so
naturally that none of it feels like
it's you know
I don't know you're just not thinking
about like the mechanics of the script
or the structure or anything like that I
think they managed to depict A really
lovely uh and touching mess and you know
this yeah this this tale of this broken
little family who gets a little bit
bigger and maybe a little bit stronger
and a little bit more assured in just
you know what their unique Harmony is
and can be and I think that's lovely and
I think yeah again like making this
maybe not exactly a musical but a medley
and a sort of review of sorts uh was
really nice and just yeah like feeling
like uh through very practical means
like you're exploring the island and
getting a little taste of you know each
part of life here and what there is to
do uh David too I thought you know while
the love you know the romantic story of
him wanting to date Nani isn't like
super duper in uh the foreground or
anything like that like I thought he was
quite Charming a nice addition I ship
them I'm happy if he becomes
uncle or brother-in-law or whatever that
is
um and yeah just like this was a really
nice array of characters a lot of really
tender moments I mean this made me cry
multiple times like this was super fun
it made me laugh
um and God the the use of that ugly
duckling like that page and the way they
animated it here too it's got that same
quality just like the way that duck
looks so perturbed and and lost and sad
and just like I'm lost uh like it always
hits me in the fields you know and and
yeah I think they made it like a really
nice ugly duckling story out of the tale
of the both of them but also you can
really kind of apply it to a lot of what
characters are going through in this
because you know in associating with
each other they're all being alienated
from the norm of society and they're all
sort of searching for the place that
they fit the most and I like that by the
end you know even the status quo at
least of the aliens learns to you know
open them so elves up and I love that
loophole of like they're all about the
rules and since you got stitched from
the pound and you have a legal document
that says you paid whatever two dollars
for him then hey we gotta abide by that
we'll check in once in a while you know
uh that's just yeah it was super lovely
Ving Rhames too as bubbles like I loved
that I love the reveal of that I should
have known he was basically one of the
Men in Black at that point in time and I
feel like this is uh this would have
been there's a little bit of Men In
Black in the DNA of this I mean you know
there's uh certainly the aliens feel
like they could easily fit into that
Universe just as a whole and uh you know
Stitch wouldn't be out of place in that
universe so maybe head Cannon they're
the same and maybe Ving Rhames is just
one of the actual Men In Black even
though he says he's CIA it's fine
um but yeah like this was so lovely I
loved all the design work and stuff like
that uh you know you even got your Chase
sequence in there like there's this so
much and again it never feels like it's
too fast or or you know too slight or
anything like that and every frame all
the artwork is just so rich like hell
yeah man like this going back to each of
these movies is always fun and
interesting because you never know and
there's also a little bit of pressure
because you never know how you're gonna
feel and you know there's also there's
just that idea that like I don't wanna
I've heard this is great it's Timeless
it's listed the test of time I hope I
like it as much as everybody else does I
hope I see what everybody else sees in
it and this is one where I feel like I
really definitely did and uh yeah I am
coming out of this experience just in
the Here and Now with you know a warm
heart and also just like the the urge to
put this on again like the great thing
is like this movie is really touching
and it doesn't shy away from the hard
things or the Bittersweet things or the
sad things that lets you sit with the
emotion I love when uh what is that Tia
Carrera uh I love when Nani sings to
Lilo in there like that's a really sweet
moment and like the way in which yeah
like they depict again like the struggle
to keep it together when you're driving
each other up a wall because you're both
kind of having your own reactions to a
harsh situation
um but yeah like the the way they got
you to the point where you're like man
there's no coming back like this All Is
Lost and then the way they resolve
everything by the end was just like
really well thought out really
satisfying uh loved just the the
esoteric little uh population of people
poor ice cream guy
um just yeah just like everything got a
little kiss of
personality and TLC and I would you know
just as soon as yeah like recommend this
to somebody as like a quality film as I
would put it on just to kind of be
inside of its Vibe and all that and I
hope that the extended media from this
is good is it you know maintains a
certain quality because uh you know like
this seems like one of those ones that's
really special and I hope uh I don't
know it just made me miss this kind of
Animation you know it made me miss uh
the the drawn animation style where even
if it is assisted with computers you can
tell that yes like this is pieces of Art
and this is yeah some of this is like a
big watercolor painting that they then
animated on top of like you know like
this is a wonderful tradition of Cinema
and then I think of stuff like Strange
World which I really want to see uh and
I feel bad because I'm like I love when
they do sci-fi stuff like this not the
strange world is necessarily the exact
same kind of movie as this or is aiming
for the feels that this is aiming for
but like
this was such a cool convergence of
things that I love so anyway I feel like
I have probably talked your ear off long
enough if you've made it to this point
which if you did thank you so much
because uh yeah I don't know I love
dishing on these movies and I love
getting to check them out and uh yeah I
thought this was a blast uh and I cannot
wait to watch it again so leave me your
thoughts leave me anything I missed
talking about or anything you want to
point out to me any trivia any other
movies from this era I should check out
there are at least a couple other ones I
probably haven't seen you know try your
luck you never know uh yeah much love to
you guys and hey before we end this
thing off let's do a patreon
Chase Gardener my Demon Slayer dude
among many other fandoms we have shared
over time I'm taking a gamble on this
one and hoping that maybe this movie
would be up your alley and maybe you'll
be like sweet a Lilo and Stitch shout
out well well let's let's shout out but
everyone was doing this for us that's
the that's the hook no that cannot be
the hook of this Shadow I'm so sorry
that would be so annoying to listen to
prolonged not that this isn't but uh
dude Chase thank you so much for just
being here for so long and for you know
really just continuing to bring such
enthusiasm you crash landed in our
little ecosystem our little mosquito
Sanctuary out here the reject nation and
you're always good at bringing me the
hype and I hope that in 2023 I I hope
someone is bringing you the hype maybe
even like if you had like an actual hype
guy following you around like a hype man
that would be the coolest but even just
you know people supporting you and
making you feel uh loved and as though
you can achieve your aspirations your
goals your hopes and and Beyond that's I
mean we should all be so lucky man so I
hope that's going on for you and I am
just glad to have you as part of our
little rejection here it's always nice
getting to shout you out every month and
remembering that like damn
somewhere out there that chase Gardener
is walking around being a generous emmer
effort and uh and and it deserves to be
known
so thanks buddy I hope you're having a
good year and uh we'll chat soon much
love and uh yeah as always cheers
[Music]